انظر إلى بيضة القرن لبيضة أمريكية
هذه البيضة السوداء ، قد يبدو
الأمر غريبًا أن تضعه في فمك ،
قد تبدأ هناك ساشا ، هذه
القصة الكبيرة مستوحاة من تكوين
بيضة القرن الملقب بيضة عمرها ألف عام
بيضة الألفية  هي ببساطة
البيضة السوداء هي بيضة محفوظة
تعتبر طعامًا شهيًا في الصين ،
لا يوجد سوى عدد قليل من الأشخاص الذين
يواصلون صنعها بالطريقة التقليدية
بما في ذلك زوج الزوج والزوجة
هذا ، وهو بلا شك ذرة يتم إنشاء بيضة قرن من
خلال الخلط  ملح الجير الحي للشاي
ورماد الخشب المحترق حديثًا بالماء
لتكوين طين مثل عجينة البيض الخام ،
ثم يتم تغطيتها في عجينة ملفوفة في
قشور الأرز حتى لا تلتصق ببعضها البعض توضع
في وعاء وتترك لتجلس كما
يوحي الاسم لمائة  سنوات على
ما يرام ، يبدو أنهم كانوا
يجلسون منذ مائة عام في
قتل كندا بأمان لهذه الوصفة ، أرجوك أنا
طالب ضابط يلقي به بعضًا من هاتامي كيف أن
Kingdom on no ، أفتقد الشخص الذي
يعني أنه حار هناك ليو متأكد من فعل ذلك
إن أصول الطبق عبارة عن أساطير غامضة تم
تتبع الخلق منذ أكثر من
500 عام إلى عهد أسرة مينج عندما
اكتشف مزارع خط بيض البط
المحفوظ بشكل طبيعي في بركة موحلة من
الماء
اليوم ، غالبًا ما يتم تناول بيضة القرن
خلال المناسبات الخاصة في هذه اللحظة.
كان لديه أي بطريق ياباني
ينظم مع عادة ما بالطبع
ليس كل شخص معجبًا في البداية
ماذا يقول ما هو
الشيء الذي هو رئيس ولكن بالنسبة
للملايين والملايين الذين يحبون أكل
بيض القرن ،
العم وو ابن العمة المخطط
لمواصلة جعلهم ما كان موجودًا حتى الآن مع ذلك ،
لذا فأنت متأكد جدًا من النطاق لأنه في
أي مكان كان موجودًا في أي مكان
[موسيقى]